♪♪
Narrator:
Would you describe your child as
strong-willed,...
♪♪
Narrator:
...rambunctious,...
♪♪
Narrator:
...unkempt?
(Ahh)
Narrator:
Has their sleep been irregular?
Do they have mysterious
scratches?
Narrator:
Have your laundry loads doubled
in size?
Narrator:
Have they gone feral?
(Howling)
Narrator:
Have you been wondering
what exactly changed?
Narrator:
Well there's an answer to your
question.
Narrator:
Your child just might be...a
"Wolfwalker".
♪♪
Sean Óg:
She's one of them Wolfwalkers.
Wolfwalkers?
The one's that can talk to
wolves.
Narrator:
Raising a Wolfwalker is a
demanding job,
Narrator:
but ultimately rewarding.
You have four legs now, you can
run really fast.
Narrator:
Here are a few tips that may
help you adjust.
(Burping)
(Bird squawking)
Narrator:
First, make sure your child gets
plenty of time in nature.
Stay here in the forest, it's
great.
Narrator:
And they'll need exercise, lots
of exercise.
Narrator:
And you should probably keep an
eye on them.
Narrator:
Wolfwalkers have a way of
getting into trouble.
(Chicken clucking)
What?
Stay inside, do as you're told.
Narrator:
A Wolfwalker child can be a
handful.
Narrator:
So remember to reach out when
you need a helping hand.
Narrator:
Some people don't quite
understand the
Narrator:
wild nature of a Wolfwalker.
(Barking)
(Bell ringing)
Wolf, wolf!
Narrator:
So make sure they're
self-reliant
Narrator:
and resourceful.
(Kids "aww")
Narrator:
And don't forget about
self care.
Narrator:
Because you aren't going to get
any sleep with a Wolfwalker on your hands.
(Aww)
-Narrator:
For additional tips watch "Wolfwalkers" on Apple TV+.
♪♪
(Howling)